[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice george camel ramsey personality
is my co-host today we're answering your
questions about your life and your money
you will know george's voice from
several of our podcasts the borrowed
future podcast which millions of you
have downloaded now the new fine print
podcast which is uh
wow it's come out of the gate like a
super popular thing because it is very
well done and of course he's the host of
the entree leadership podcast so fine
print is uh has dropped another episode
this week we got 10 episodes total and
this was like number seven right yeah
yeah the dirty truth about credit scores
that's one you've been railing against
for years dave and so i just wanted to
once and for all you can send this to
your friends and go just listen to this
listen to this 25-minute episode on
credit scores to get the skinny yeah
because you we've done one on bitcoin it
was very good listen to it i listened to
the one on uh the uh miles and points oh
credit card that was well done well done
chuck e cheese that was a good chuck e
cheese
best analogy i could come up with i'm
well played well played because it's
beautiful too i mean it's the exact same
thing yeah it's all it's all
psychological sticky hands gamification
sticky hands you gotta have them open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five as we answer your
questions about your life
and your money
shane is with us shane is in
indianapolis hi shane how are you
hey dave i'm doing well how about
yourself better than we deserve what's
up
well great um my wife and i are seeing a
move in the next one to three years
i'm debt free other than my house i owe
115 000 on on the house right now
and i have 125 000 in cash and then i
also have twenty thousand dollars of an
emergency fund
um
thanks so i wonder just do i pay out the
house now or
knowing that we're probably going to
move you know in the next one to three
years do i continue on the path that i'm
on of just stacking away cash or i'll
pay it off and then you can stack more
cash because you don't have a house
payment yeah
yep okay
that's impressive
how did you save up 125 thousand dollars
i'm just curious
um
we just kind of had a wildly important
goal of my my wife staying at home and
um we thought the best path
of doing this um
you know is to pay off the house and to
remain debt free so
early on we started off um
we took your financial peace university
before we got married and we've kind of
uh just always
lived by your rules and principles
you're doing extremely well i'm very
proud of you let's back into why i said
to do that okay
you're gonna move anyway obviously
you know that when you sell the house
they're gonna give you a check so you're
not losing the money you're not spending
the money you're not consuming the money
it's just changing positions
which asset is parked in right and so
you're doing away with
a mortgage and your interest rate is
higher than your savings rate on your
savings account
so you're mathematically going to win a
tiny tiny bit there but it's not really
worth doing it for that what will happen
is this and this is what i it took me
probably
15 or 20 years of doing this before i
really gave credit to this because i'm a
math nerd i wanted everything to be a
math thing
but here's a weird thing you make biff
different decisions with a paid for
house
yeah
you just do because you're your head
space you're where you are spiritually
where you are relationally changes
and so i'm not saying you'll stay
because it's paid for
i'm saying you're gonna kind of feel um
very confident edging on cocky as a
seller
because i don't have to sell it
and um i'm you know i'm going to get a
price and there's nothing pushing this
there's no there's no uh
i just don't have to be in a hurry
because i don't have any payments
also you're going to be able to pile up
cash like a crazy man because you don't
have the house payment anymore that
works too
and you're obviously very good at that
congratulations again i'm very
impressive
uh but but
you know even stuff like uh you know
another wave of covid comes through or
uh uh or just a wave of political
stupidity comes through which seems to
be coming in the tsunami level these
days but the uh uh but you know if you
just keep this you know something comes
through all these external variables
that we don't have control over
our spirits and our decision making
is much cleaner and wiser when we're
sitting in a paid for house than when
we're sitting with 115 120 000 in the
bank and not a paid for house it's just
weird and it does it's there's no math
to it it's just a the borrower is slave
to the lender and the slave when he no
longer has a master is known as free
and it just you know think about
a slave and how their mentality changes
and that's a
there is something to that that is
beyond just the apparent mathematics
yeah absolutely and not only that but
you're saving on interest you're going
to pay to this bank you're freeing up
the payment and you said at the
beginning you have this wildly important
goal so that your wife can stay home and
so if you can do that earlier now with a
paid for house this is fantastic news
well she's probably already done it i
mean it's just
incredible very very well done sharp
young couple and i'm glad that uh what
we do at ramsey was able to add value to
somebody like that's life yeah very more
of that i want to see that happen all
over the yeah i mean what problems to
have i have the money in the bank to pay
off my house should i do it this is a
there's a better much better question
than i'm four payments behind yes how do
i stop the foreclosure yeah because we
have done detailed research and 100 of
the foreclosures occur on a home with a
mortgage ironclad data it's just
straight up there's no question about it
so there is risk associated with it and
we just do not perceive the risk because
we all understand that housing is such a
good investment real estate's such a
stable investment by and large and so we
don't assign any emotionally and
spiritually any risk to the process now
shane wasn't pushing back but some of
your you know
dave ramsey lost his mind he told that
32 year old guy pay off his house he
should have been telling me no no dave's
not lost his mind
the
instructions i gave him were the
shortest distance between where he is
now and wealthy
and we know this from the millionaire
data yeah and we're seeing this where a
lot of people have a stack of cash and
they go well dave doesn't make sense to
pay off the house i could invest that
the market's doing so well right now it
is but those people have never felt the
feeling of having a paid for house
without mortgage payment
and here's the thing too if you don't
think there's an emotional element to it
just reverse the process what if you
were sitting with um
ten thousand dollars in the bank instead
of 125 000
and your house was paid for
would you go borrow
115 on your house in order to put
it in the bank can have 125 in the bank
with a mortgage
reverse the process
and i bet i mean i i would say 98
percent of the time i ask the question
in reverse like that people just go well
no
but it's a trick question because it
tricks you to thinking with your heart
not just your head and your heart's
where you measure risk your math where
you do math oh that was good your head's
where you do math your heart's where you
measure risk and you just kind of you
have an almost a visceral reaction to
that no i wouldn't do that
but well it's the same thing yeah you
get excited about seeing that money grow
in an investment but you don't take into
account the risk when you do that but
when you talk about borrowing money on a
paid for house you feel the risk
for the first time yeah all of a sudden
all of your
end quotes air quotes sophisticated math
goes out the window yep yeah i say air
quotes because it's not sophisticated
because you left out risk and
sophisticated math would include risk
this is the ramsey show
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile
they can personally invite you to apply
for the job so if you're ready for an
easier job search check out ziprecruiter
sign up for free right now at
ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is also the host of the
ever popular
podcast the fine print be sure and check
it out ramsey network's producing all
kinds of wonderful podcasts these days
and we've got a little documentary
coming out tomorrow it's big dave it's
not little nothing little about it and
i'm telling you it's a big deal i've
been doing media all over the nation
they're wearing me out around here and
i'm about to do about 20 more hits
tomorrow on it to promote it and it is
uh
it's gonna be mammoth i mean i'm so
excited about it it's so well done
borrowed future how student loans are
killing the american dream
the epic
failure
of the student loan program
you watch this with you're gonna go
every teenager in america needs to see
this and every parent of every teenager
needs to see see this so they grow a
backbone and don't allow their kids to
make some of the mistakes that people
make all the time 45 million americans
in student loan debt
that's a lot
wow it's crazy yeah i just talked to
seth fratman the other day who's
featured in the documentary and he was
giving me the update on where things are
at two years later because we
interviewed him back in 2019 and let me
tell you it's it's dismal not a lot has
changed no the hope that people had uh
they're still hoping they're waiting
with baited breath for forgiveness and
new legislation and the new president
and is he going to do what he said he
was going to do
and we just want people to be free and
take to take control for themselves yeah
if you wait on washington to bless your
home you're going to be a loser your
whole life
your home has to be blessed by you and
your hands and your work and your
decisions and your critical thinking
skills that's what's going to happen
that's real
so yeah
these are the people that get out of
student loan debt and the you know the
public student loan forgiveness program
98 of those that apply for forgiveness
denied
people paid 10 years
work a job that wouldn't work
and 10 years later
98 tonight that's called lying
if if anything else had that pass fail
right i mean i wouldn't exist today yeah
that's called lying to your constituents
when the federal government makes you a
promise that 98 of the people don't cash
in on can't cash in on are denied
dedication on it's a lie is what that is
it's just it's it's criminal is what it
is it's like trying to cancel comcast
it's nearly impossible
very few people
are able to withstand well have you ever
tried to cancel a discover card it's not
it's right there next to it yeah that's
it that's the truth right there man
so anyway check it out apple tv google
play amazon prime and borrowed future
dot com if you are a teacher
and you would like to show this
documentary to your teens or pre-teens
uh it's free
for you as a teacher to show to your
classroom we're not going to charge you
a dime or college even i don't care just
tell me you're a teacher go to borrowed
future.com
and we will set you up with that
if you're a sunday school teacher and
you want to show it to your teen
for teenagers and you want to show it to
them i we want to we want to cause a
holy ruckus with this it's time
it's time someone stood up and said this
is wrong
the actors are bad actors
there's so many villains it was hard to
tell the story yeah a good story has one
villain and one hero and it is very
difficult it's a terrible story this
one's it's like it's like a bad saturday
morning cartoon that got out of control
yeah i mean it's just it's a bad thing
but it's it's a
you won't be able to put it down people
that have watched it in the previews oh
man you can't unsee it at the end you
have to make a decision you have to go
what do i believe about this am i going
to support the system exactly kimberly
is in san antonio hi kimberly welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave how are you doing today better
than i deserve how can we help
i'm a little nervous right now it's okay
we've never lost a page
okay thank you thank you
um so we we're an active duty uh family
thank you for your service
thank you i appreciate it um i just have
some questions all my questions are
related up to our military lifestyle
uh i guess my first question is going to
be about the
service members civil relief act
um how we can use that in our advantage
um
in my for us personally we don't uh we
have zero percent interest in all of our
credit cards
due to that act
and how can we use that in a in our
advantage that would be
uh my first question
um
i can go into the others but i really
want to tackle these well the biggest
thing there is uh that the service
relief act gives us two things one is
you've got the zero percent that you're
able to say okay 100 of what i pay on
this credit credit card debt goes on the
principal so it's a real opportunity uh
while apparently someone is
not only active duty but deployed into a
combat zone right
correct yeah but um
yeah it has varieties but we have been
participating for a few years already
okay then you're in there good so yeah
so 100 of what you pay on these credit
cards is going to get rid of them so
chop them up and let's list them
smallest to largest as far as the debt
rate goes and attack them with a
vengeance the other part of the act that
sometimes folks have to use and we've
used in financial coaching with the
military for years
is that if you are behind on something
uh like a behind on a car payment or
behind on rent or behind on a house
payment the creditor cannot foreclose or
repossess on you because you're falling
to that act
uh until you guys get back and
everybody's you know not deployed into a
combat zone and get back active and so
forth but that's probably not gonna
apply to you but the whole thing is when
you got zero percent instead of eighteen
percent you know let's take advantage of
that and use that extra that same thing
with those those of you sitting on
student loans right now you have zero
percent so let's let's just use this
time not to sit around and twiddle our
thumbs and go oh we don't have to be in
a hurry we have zero percent no this is
get in a hurry time
yeah and that's what we're seeing it
reminded me of the student loan extended
relief where it's zero percent people go
well i'm going to take advantage of this
but the real way to take advantage of it
is to pay off all your debt and get rid
of it so i don't know how much debt
kimberly has on this or if she's just
saying how do i take advantage of this
card going forward there is no way to
take advantage of debt that's not really
a gift yeah it takes advantage of you
felicity is in newark new jersey hi
felicity how are you
great thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so my husband and i are debt-free we're
currently about 30 000 into renting to
own it's an interest-free contract with
the option to buy it back excuse me to
back out or to buy out at any time
um if you're a close family friend of
ours who's now looking to close his
rental business and while he's obviously
still willing to carry through on our
agreement contract he approached us with
the option of avoiding the agreement we
have
to instead purchase the house for a
dollar
both him and ourselves using his lawyer
and then essentially draw up a second
agreement that was basically a personal
loan between him and ourselves for the
remainder of what we owe him on the rent
to end this would also be interest-free
but um since we're doing him a favor as
well as paying the lawyer fees he would
deduct our total amount by like 10 to 15
000
but my husband and i are just a little
nervous we're not sure if that's
possible or smart to do and what kind of
tax transfer issues we would run into
since it would look like we paid a
dollar for the house when really we
didn't
wow
you're not going to run into any
problems uh you may need to
pay more recording fees than than you
would pay on a dollar because that is
going to be weird uh you may want to
give assign an actual value because
you're
in most states i don't know how jersey
works but in most states when you when
you record the deed for the house you're
taxed on the amount of the sale at that
time the warranty deed okay which is
your title all right and so you're
probably not going to want to try to
pull that off at a dollar that's going
to create problems for you but other
than that
um
i
this sounds a little um
why does he not want a lien on the house
why is he making it a personal loan
it's just a close family friend i mean
he doesn't know but there's no point
there's no point that's just weird
it's not like it's not really doing you
a favor
and it leaves him in a very very weak
position
doesn't hurt you your position's fine
see if you don't pay and he's got a lien
on the house he could foreclose on the
house you don't pay in this situation he
just has to sue you like it's an
unsecured debt exactly
yeah
there's no harm in what you're outlining
i would have an attorney draft it all
pay be willing to pay some attorneys
fees to make sure this is done
the way it's described here but um
it feels like he's hiding something from
someone else
is what it feels like he's trying to
keep his money off the grid somehow
because of course when you record when
you have a mortgage it's recorded at the
courthouse a personal loan just between
you and him
there's no public record of it so it
sounds like this guy's trying to get off
the grid or something i don't know
be careful because it's an unusual
transaction so
i don't know that there's a rat but
there's hints of rats here
little nose for the rat
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much pure
talk gives you the same great 5g
coverage on the same 5g network as one
of the big guys for half the cost the
average family saves over 800 a year go
to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage adam
and olivia are with us hey guys how are
you great how are you dave better than
we deserve george hey hey george where
do you guys live
uh verona new york cool welcome to
nashville and all the way here to do a
debt-free screen how much do you pay off
172
630. way to go and how long did that
take 27 months
all right and your range of income
during that time 126 000 to 190 000. wow
nice jump in 27 months what do you guys
do for a living i am a maintenance and
facilities engineer at aerospace company
and i'm a project manager for a
commercial millwork company okay so how
does your income go up seventy thousand
sixty five thousand bucks during twenty
seven months change jobs you got new
jobs both of you yes oh wow what
precipitated that
uh wasn't happy where he was just wanted
more money oh yeah and it was there so
we're gonna go get it correct absolutely
i like it good for you guys what kind of
debt was the hundred and seventy three
thousand we had uh we had a wide range
we had credit cards student loans
personal loans we had uh some medical
debt some uh
previous marriage debt and uh oh yeah we
uh paid off our house our house whoa
look at the weird people
how old are you guys i'm 30. 37. and a
paid for house
you are so weird
i love it what's this house worth uh
right now right around 200 000.
you own it baby you own it it's yours
yeah
we originally bought it about seven
years ago for 40 000. whoa we've been
flipping it since then oh my goodness so
well done so on top of paying off the
debt we've also done a few renovations
sounds like sounds like a couple yeah
wow that's beautiful i'm watching it on
the screen here and it looks gorgeous
yeah renovations i also one of my side
jobs was to design kitchen so i was able
to design ours and actually work in the
wood shop to pay for the kitchen and i
did all the construction you guys are
incredible
so what made you
27 months ago you know what not only are
we going to tackle all this debt we're
going to tackle the house too well
honestly it started um i had changed
jobs back then from my first one out of
college and i had this
retirement account that i didn't know
what to do with since i was changing
companies and we met with a financial
advisor shout out to michelle thank you
so much who introduced us to dave ramsey
and his principals and the rest was
history
just like that just like that we were on
board from the start he was a little
hesitant when i wanted a financial
advisor to come over he's like well how
much is this going to cost but once we
got done through the meeting we were all
in there was never a fight to go on this
plan right oh my goodness way to go guys
excellent job wow so you just plugged
into the podcast or what yes
watched a lot of them watch a lot of
youtube videos we we just went went to
town on watching you yeah about a half
an hour commute each way um so that was
all it was on the car i love it well we
are honored thank you i'm glad we added
value you guys are incredible well done
i'm proud of you who was your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you i
would say michelle was probably one of
the biggest cheerleaders
you're you're a financial advisor
financial advisor our parents are
obviously super proud of us and um our
oldest son aiden loved to see us color
in our chart every week and was so happy
and cheering us on and excited to get to
that next line yeah what made you guys
plow through this so quickly i mean you
have a great income but most people
would go you know we'll we'll get this
thing done but you decided to do it in
just over two years we sold a lot we we
did so a lot uh just running the numbers
through excel spreadsheets i was like i
think we could do this and we just put
our minds through indebted we took a lot
of side jobs uh like she said we sold
off a lot of stuff i sold my corvette a
porsche
a corvette and a porsche
so you said you know what it's worth it
i'm gonna sacrifice get rid of some of
these toys and i can have all the toys
later on exactly wow that's big deal
what did the porsche and the corvette
sell for uh not as much as you think uh
the one they were both fixer-uppers and
they were just gonna be projects and i
just never got around to actually doing
anything with them okay so they were
actually gonna be a money drain correct
because of the if a project car they
you could spend some money on that
exactly
wow
wow
okay all of this sacrifice you're
working like crazy you're selling
everything you're in the wood shop
making your own cabinets all this
sacrifice
you've been busting it
for 27 months
was it worth it
very much so
and it's hard to get out of that mindset
it was hard to
to
say hey we're gonna we're gonna put this
money aside just to travel down here for
this about i mean we we knew we wanted
this the whole time and
so we made it happen yeah when you bust
through the end of it it's like okay
what now because it feels like i have to
slow down
it's kind of weird isn't it yeah yeah we
enjoy watching our savings account go up
our our retirement account go up our
401ks our roth iras everything
and it's kind of hard watching any of it
go yeah but still working hard to get
that house finished oh yeah yeah you'll
get there it's going to be amazing well
done you guys very well done
excellent excellent job
so what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is
is track track drag just like you said
but put a name on every single dollar
just uh just keep track of everything
you spend and don't be afraid to ask why
why why do we have to spend this do we
really have to do we really need this
working together being on the same page
yeah you guys do seem there's a you can
just almost an air of unity yeah i mean
they are so close together they might
fuse into one person
just physically right now i love it it's
such a key every time we see a couple
like this they're always holding hands
hugging there's always this sense of
unity that did you did your marriage
grow during this journey in 27 months
and more than i ever thought we uh
it not only grew it kind of divided a
little bit
made a new one
all right here we go
i like it that's good stuff
all right so you brought the kiddos with
you to do the debt-free scream what are
their names and ages we have aiden he's
nine
and this is connor the new one he is six
months all right and that's who we were
just discussing yeah
way to go connor you did it man good job
all right you can get free from sherry
there good all right that's fun good
stuff good stuff we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's the next
chapter in your story you're going to be
every baby steps millionaires before you
know it if you're not already well done
very well done and a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give it away
and pay it forward to somebody and get
them started and 27 months later maybe
they'll be standing here you never know
we would love that that's how that's how
this stuff gets spread so thank you guys
so much definitely uh looking forward to
watching on the borrowed future ah
welcome well i'll tell you what we're
going to set you up with a uh with a
free view of it we're going to do that
as part of the package you'll be in here
today it'll be perfect
we'll take care of that for you our
oldest daughter is 17 and she's about
ready to go to college next year oh wow
this will uh this will scare you
straight right here i'm just saying good
good work you guys excellent excellent
work all right it's adam and olivia
aiden and connor 173 000 paid off in 27
months house and everything not even 40
years old 126 190 000 income during that
time count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three
two
one
[Applause]
well done i think that baby knows he's
dead free i can see it on his face conor
connor i mean hayden does the countdown
this is good i could hear him he didn't
have a microphone and we could hear him
see this is uh
this is how family tree's changed
now he may not remember a lot but he's
when he's 29 he'll remember that time
his parents came and stood on stage in
nashville
and yelled because they'd sacrificed and
worked like crazy
to change their family tree and when
he's 29 out there walking around he's
going to be making completely different
decisions because of this yeah the the
modeling that you do before your
children and involving them in this
process
is as important as you becoming wealthy
in terms of you if you want to change
your family tree you can leave an idiot
ten million dollars they'll go through
it but if you raise children that aren't
idiots and because you modeled before
them and you you know they'll win like
one guy said the other day i was on the
uh every day on the everyday millionaire
hour i said would you inherit from your
family he said work ethic oh i love that
you know character is more important to
pass yeah morning morris caught than
taught and uh he caught a lot watching
his parents sacrifice for 27 months way
to go aiden incredible good job man well
done well done well done good stuff
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well we've all been hearing the crazy
stats around the great resignation
one study says 55 percent of americans
are looking for a new job
that's over half of you another report
says that one in three workers are
looking for more meaningful work
if you're one of those folks looking for
a job right now you know the job market
is really competitive in that sea of
talent passion and experience you can
stand out if you're clear
on what your strengths and purpose are
when it comes to your career ken
coleman's brand new book from paycheck
to purpose helps you get a grip
on your purpose
and it gives you the proven plan and
clear path to doing the work you love
this year taught a lot of people that
you don't have to settle for just a
j-o-b you can make a real impact when
you're doing work that you're actually
passionate about pre-order ken's book
from paycheck to purpose today and get
over 100 in free bonus items to coach
you through your job search process
including free resume templates and a
free video course with advice to help
you nail down a job interview
get your copy from paycheck to purpose
today at ramseysolutions.com
we appreciate you guys listening george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
new podcast the fine print is my co-host
today darren is with us in chicago hi
darren how are you
hey i'm doing pretty well how are you
guys doing better than we deserve what's
up
i just want to first say just thank you
guys for all that you do really
appreciate uh you and all your your team
there well thank you
um so my question is uh so my wife is an
interior designer right now and um she's
wanting to
start her own interior design business
in the next few years and i was just
wondering if i could get some advice on
how i could be
you know just kind of a better
encourager to help motivate her
and just kind of be that support person
behind her um
when when sometimes she does kind of
have you know a lack of confidence in
her ability to to be able to do that
yeah absolutely first of all i think
it's awesome that you are calling in on
behalf to to want to show that level of
support how serious is she about this
business right now
is it just kind of a dream
um it is a dream but she's you know like
working towards uh
to be able to do that um right now she
works for a pretty big firm uh
architecture firm
um and so you know she's been getting
more into reading different materials
getting into like christie's uh material
and just trying to set herself up
whenever she is ready to kind of make
that leap
um
you know i know you guys always always
say don't try to kind of get the boat a
little bit closer to the dock before
kind of making that leap so she's trying
to kind of position herself to kind of
start
dabbling in that more and more yeah
there's a lot of people that are um what
we call makers
um
that
make uh
that often make the error
of uh because they're good at doing a
thing
they think they need to do a business of
that they they're good at cooking and so
they're a good chef so they need to run
a restaurant
cooking is a different
skill set than running a restaurant is
uh they they're good at uh being a uh a
web developer and so they need to open a
digital web development company no
you're there it's different skill set um
they're good at uh sales and so they
need to be promoted to sales manager uh
now it's a different skill set to manage
sales people than to actually be one and
so on and and so you're good painter a
house painter and so you want to open a
house painting business well it's
different skill set to run a business
and it is paint houses
so that's the first area i would
encourage her in is
not to recognize how good she is at home
decorating i think that's already
established she's probably pretty
confident about that where her lack of
confidence and her fear will come up is
is
wise fear
in that she realizes she's getting ready
to become an executive in business and
doesn't know how
and so now dive into christie's
materials and learn how to run a
business and then when she's learning
the different components of business
from entre leadership from the business
boutique brand from christie
then um you know you can do any i don't
i couldn't spell digital five years ago
now the company i run is basically a
digital company and i'm the ceo of a 300
million dollar company
so but i don't i sit in the meetings
with these digital people i don't even
know what they're saying sometimes and i
own the place
but i don't but i don't have to have the
digital skills i do have to have the
executive skills to
herd the cats towards a common goal
and a vision and setting that and
keeping everybody in the in their lane
and uh listening to the experts and
going with learning enough to where i
can make a good solid um
decision and so executive skills are
gathering up people to do things you
don't know how to do and helping
everybody going the right direction
yeah part of that is figuring out is
this a hobby is this something i can do
on the side and i still get joy from
that versus when you do it full-time and
this happened to me with music i tried
to go in full-time into music and
realize you know what i'm running a
business and i don't want to be running
a business i got into it because i love
making music yeah and so that's
something that she needs to dig into and
maybe she does it on the side for now
and as it grows she may say you know
what i do want to be my own boss i want
to take this thing full time and that's
when you can come along cider and
support her with anything she needs yeah
and you know so what i the encouragement
is going to be you don't know how to do
that so what most executives don't
they don't know how to do the thing that
they run necessarily
uh
and so the key to running a business is
not to be an expert on the thing the key
to running a business is being expert on
getting people that are smarter than you
in certain areas to all work together in
concert you are the orchestra conductor
you don't have to play the violin but
you do have to get the violin to come in
at the proper time with the oboe yeah
and darren notice i worked oboe into
this i'm impressed that was one of those
words i didn't know that you would work
in today dave no that didn't when i got
up this morning i thought i'm going to
work oboe into the first hour
my bingo card is now full yes
so darren what i love to do is gift your
wife a ticket to the business boutique
live stream she can tune in from chicago
and it's happening this weekend dave's
going to be speaking there and i think
this will give her some real
encouragement and really put down on
paper what this dream is what it's gonna
take to get there and then at least you
know there's some facts on the ground
where you can go all right is this
something we're gonna do what is the
next step i can take and if it's
confidence thing christy is a master at
that and she's going to
have a little bit more if not a lot more
confidence after viewing this event so
we'll have kelly pick up and make sure
that she has access to that live stream
and maybe you watch it with her that
would be a cool thing to do to support
her yeah christy has a talk on fear that
even fear is afraid of
i believe that you don't mess with
christy she's a beast
[Laughter]
in the best kind of way pretty
incredible speaker pretty incredible
communicator so uh yeah if you're
worried about
the fear in the face of what's going on
in business you need to tune into
business boutique this weekend uh you
don't want to miss her and uh
i'll be speaking dr john dolone several
of the ramsey folks will be there and
the lineup is off the charts cool but of
course christy is the star
so open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money
george it is interesting
there's something that occurs
um
in the human spirit and it goes back to
starting and running your own business
like that but also has to do with any
area of your life
that you don't know something about
you can learn about it yeah information
is accessible
you can you know you don't i don't know
i've never been good with money okay
you know
get a free uh
you know get get a free trial to ramsey
plus and start working your way through
financial peace university we'll show
you how to it's built for people that
didn't know how to handle money it's not
built for people with an mba i mean mbas
go through it all the time but if you've
got a phd in finance you're going to be
going well this is very primitive well
um yeah because the stuff that you do
doesn't work so we had to teach people
stuff that works and so you know but i
mean
i can't tell you when i got married how
many marriage books i started reading
because i discovered i'm pretty bad at
this i don't know how to do it and then
when i started having kids i'm like oh
they didn't come with a manual
no instruction when i brought them home
from the hospital you know
you know nobody to teach me i gotta
learn how i mean training a dog you
gotta you gotta learn from somebody
because you don't
you know
and so in it the point is you can learn
almost anything if you want to bad
enough yeah and i found that i've got so
many books sitting on the shelf that i
thought i want to learn about and i
found that what i care about is what i
invest my time into and so if you're big
into interior designing you're going to
figure out a way to do it you're going
to watch youtube clips you're going to
read books you're going to talk to
mentors and you're going to figure out a
way to do it but you have to want it
badly enough you get a fire in your
belly yep and then you can you can learn
anything now
i mean it's accessible information is
accessible and you don't have to be a
genius so don't don't ever say
i'm not good at blank blank you can say
i choose not to be good at blank blank
but
you're not good at it because you chose
not to learn more about it whatever it
is
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsay show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paying off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us america george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print
podcast among others is my co-host today
open phones as we talk to you about your
life and your money this is a weird talk
radio show because it's about
you
it's not about me
not about it not even about george
shock i thought that was gonna be the
answer dave shock it it's all about
george no no it's not no sorry george
not about me my feelings aren't you guys
so it's weird because most talk radio is
about the guy on the microphone and
we're not the hero in this story you are
we're just showing you how to do it open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five asheville north
carolina glen is with us hey glenn how
are you
you're doing great dave thanks for
taking my call i really really
appreciate all you do you too sir how
can we help
uh our family's been very blessed in
that uh our children are registered with
uh through my wife are part of a native
american tribe
and so they pay money into uh i guess
it's kind of a trust fund for them that
they can't access till they're 18 and
then they disperse it for a few years
after that
we have seven children and they're all
registered so my approximations uh the
oldest is 16 right now and my estimates
are that when they turn 18 it'll be in
the neighborhood of about 250 000
dollars until each beginning
so
each correct yeah
so so my question for you was
i mean i have some ideas but i wanted
your opinion on what kind of things
should we be doing in the home to teach
them about money now as well as make
sure that once they get it they don't
squander it because we know a lot of
other people that are in the same boat
and
you know they buy cars and end up in a
ditch in a few years and you know it's
it can be pretty it's pretty sad i know
it's not ten million dollars but it's to
us it's pretty substantial amount oh it
is substantial it is and this this
happens a lot and we've worked with a
lot of tribal
situations because the money has turned
out to not be a blessing
because it's caused people as you said
to fall into addiction uh to fall into a
lack of a work ethic because they think
they've got it made without working
because they're on the tribal dole and
um
it's uh
it's had a socio-economic effect that i
don't think anybody really saw it was an
unintended consequence across the board
right uh certainly certain individuals
have used it to be a blessing and others
it's it's really damaged their life
which is really sad and so we've seen
that so you guys are this is probably
what cherokee
correct correct yeah okay all right cool
yeah been there been to that harass yeah
so um
the uh yeah sure i mean i was born in
maryville so cherokee north carolina's
just up over the hill from us yeah so uh
i've been around this my whole life but
it's just become extremely profitable
because the casinos in the last uh few
decades for a lot of the tribes so
anyway all that to say um it's a little
bit like growing up in a wealthy family
only the family didn't earn the money
right and so you have to guard your kids
about against the dangers of wealth
which are sloth
a addiction and misbehavior sloth
meaning laziness
okay
and so we had to teach the ramsey kids
as an example growing up that they had
that they're entitled to nothing
don't talk to me about
entitled uh
you know a ramsey kid get jacked up
growing up if they start acting entitled
and especially if they start acting like
my dad's on the radio so i get to do so
and so i really jack you up you start
playing the dave card rachel can tell
you stories from her childhood that left
scars
and so because it's just because i was
not going to have our kids turn out as a
reality show because we built wealth and
i wanted quite the opposite the wealth
needs to be a blessing
and the money is not the problem the
problem is how you react to it and so
what you have to start teaching your
kids as early as possible is that this
is
this is not you hit the tribal lottery
this is you have a tremendous
responsibility
with great blessing comes great
responsibility
and i want you instead of feeling like
you had like you scored a touchdown
in the super bowl and like you did
something fancy because you hadn't done
nothing
you just hit the dna lottery that was it
that's all you've done
you're entitled to nothing here so
instead you need to take this money and
see it as a responsibility
to your family you know your own future
family to yourself
to your community
and so wealth is a it is a
responsibility and i want you to feel
the weight of that we did that through a
spiritual lens saying we don't own it
god owns it we're managing it for him so
we have the responsibility to be
faithful
to be trustworthy worthy of trust in
this and so there's going to be a lot of
dad speeches in your house
if you're wise
and you know teach them to work
teach them to act like this money's not
there if they act like the money's not
there they'll be just fine and that
money then can be a blessing
and they can hold it with an open hand
with a generous hand they can hold it
with a hand towards the future
um all of those kinds of things and and
so but it can be done you can teach a
kid in a rich family work ethic you can
teach them integrity you can teach them
character uh you can teach them delayed
pleasure uh you can teach them the
generosity um
but but where this all falls down is
when it becomes very all about me all
about me all about me that's the
entitled arrogant mentality that that
sometimes the truth in a sense it's like
a trust fund baby right
right yeah so
uh smart money smart kids is the book
that rachel and i did that was the
number one bestseller that addresses how
to raise kids and teach them how to
handle money we talk about this kind of
stuff in there i'll send you a copy of
it uh george what do you want to add to
that you've watched rachel and daniel
and denise around this place yeah
there's zero entitlement and all work
ethic and what i've seen glenn is that
money is going to make them more of
whoever they are and so whatever they
are at age 18 well that's how they're
going to handle that money when they get
that 250k so what i want you to do is
raise them in the best way you can walk
them through the principles of smart
money smart kids have them go through
financial peace university maybe as a
family and then you can start to go hey
what are your goals this money can then
flow through that framework that you've
worked so hard to build to where they go
cool we're going to cash flow school
we're not going to take out any debt
we're going to get ourselves a car we're
going to have a down payment for the
house we're going to have a fully funded
emergency fund and what that's going to
do is catapult them into their adult
life while their peers are hanging
behind with all these student loans and
car payments they are able to have a
paid for house at 24. yeah here's the
deal they can be college educated with
zero debt and be millionaires by 28 with
the numbers you gave me
yeah and that's kind of what i told them
i said you can you can work because you
want to not because you have to very a
very young age the rest of your life and
you can learn the real value of money
which is not what it does for me but
what it does for others
yeah it's the most valuable thing a kid
can ever learn and sometimes it takes us
kids till we're 50 to learn that one
and your kids don't have that option
because if they will 50 this is going to
screw up their lives yeah and uh it's a
scary scary thing i'm glad you brought
it up i've not answered that question
here on the air i've answered it behind
closed doors with a lot of discussions
with tribal leaders because they're
facing this
because it's created in some cases not
every case but there's too many times
it's created kind of a welfare state
mentality rather than the blessing that
it should have been yeah uh because the
the tribes are you know they're
dispersing the money to the tribe that's
the money they're making in the gambling
industry which is a
boatload of money a boatload of money
and so i'm glad the young man young
ladies are being blessed it's a good
thing
let's just make sure it is uh that they
understand they're blessed so that they
can be
a blessing
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host the last 24 months have been
hmm
a lot
hasn't it
a lot of worry a lot of wondering what's
gonna happen next a lot of uncertainty a
lot of cray cray out there
and maybe that's how you feel about your
money you're tired you're stuck you're
stretched thin it doesn't have to be
this way
the weird thing is is even in a wicked
weird environment if you have a plan
there's a sense of calm and a success
level that changes because a plan gives
you confidence when everything else is
out of control
we teach you the plan and have for
decades in a class called financial
peace university
almost 10 million people have been
through this class and it'll teach you
everything you need to know to save
money get out of debt become wealthy and
be outrageously generous
you can stream the lessons on your own
or you can even go to class with other
people and get support that way or both
then you'll put the plan into practice
with the premium version of our every
dollar budgeting app the world's best
budgeting app
it syncs up with your bank
and you can track your spending and see
where your money goes you get all of
this only with a ramsey plus membership
you don't have to stay exhausted you
don't have to be overwhelmed you can win
with money
to start your free trial of ramsey plus
text trial to 33 789 text trial to 33789
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
riley is in minnesota hi riley how are
you
oh not too bad how are you doing dave
better than i deserve what's up
okay so my question is kind of a
two-parter so i'm gonna try and keep it
as short as possible
um
when i took um personal finance my
junior year of high school my
personal finance teacher actually showed
us your
classes for her class to help prove like
reinforce for point
and
in my when i was junior i was not very
smart and i thought you were actually
quite arrogant and i didn't take your
advice but
now my grandparents recommended i
started listening to you again and now
i'm feeling really arrogant and stupid
the table's turned
well that's okay me too brother i
understand
that's exactly what i would have done in
high school i like you
if i had watched me in high school i
would have been making fun of me
that's exactly what i was doing
unfortunately because now i feel like
i've put myself in quite a bit of a
pickle what'd you do
um
well to start i don't this is gonna make
your jaw drop i don't use uh debit card
or cash i strictly use credit cards okay
what's your question for today let's try
it that way
my question for today okay um
i guess like for the first part would be
um with how
i use
actually else gets the
big problem is i am 20 years old and i
bought my house when i was 19 years old
on a
5 down payment and a 30-year loan
okay and i was wondering what should
what
should i do are you having any trouble
making the payments
no that's not the problem it's just you
after watching i've been watching your
videos again for about five days now and
you recommend
doing a 15
what is your income
my income
um
do you want that from my main job or
from all sources all sources
about 40 000. good for you
good for you okay
um well here's the thing what's the
interest rate on your mortgage
uh three percent fixed okay you don't
have to do anything with this mortgage
you just need to get yourself on a plan
and just you can pay extra on it without
refinancing it and if you pay a 30 like
a 15 it pays off in 15.
so you haven't you haven't ruined your
life you're okay
okay yeah that was just my biggest
concern is because when i bought the
house i thought of it in more of a
mathematical
thought process i guess you could say it
because the house is a
i bought it under market value because
the
area i'm in the houses are roughly 150
000 to 250 000. i got it for 110.
and i figured if i spread it out over
the next 30 years
with inflation that 112 000
will be
hundred and something thousand
and the house plus interest will be a
hundred and sixty thousand so i thought
if that plot was if i paid out the full
thirty years i'll end up saving money
through inflation
because 30 years from now
i'm going to be paying the same amount
but with money that's technically worth
less than it is now yeah but not really
and here's why okay
the house is going to go up in value due
to inflation
whether it has a mortgage or not
these are independent equations these
equations are not interconnected
and so you don't have to have a mortgage
in order for the house to go up in value
and so what if you had it paid for and
it went up in value oh now we've got the
formula on how to be a millionaire yeah
and
to the credit card thing he he wanted to
make it clear that he uses
no debit cards in cash only credit cards
there's other pieces to this equation
that you've got to figure out obviously
the mortgage is not syncing you
financially but i am worried about your
mindset when it comes to debt and so
this is something i want you to really
take a hard look at and go what other
areas am i willing to have payments on
because right now you're willing to have
the credit card payment i don't know if
you're paying it off i don't know what
other kind of debt you may have
but i think we need to change our
mindset here because you're 20 years old
and you're good at math but you're not
great at managing money and so i want
you to get better at the second part and
then the math will help you
going forward so you're doing great
riley obviously you made uh a little
ouchie here but it's not sinking you and
your income is only going to go up and
as it does i want you to pay that
mortgage off i don't know why you wanted
to hang around for 30 years that made
you made it very clear like well in 30
years no i want this thing gone in five
10 15 years because you have a life to
live and i don't know about you but i
don't want a mortgage
when i'm 50 years old
well you're getting ready to be done
with yours yeah i'm 32 and then we're
paying it off in the next four or five
months and i'm saying sayonara and i
wish i was like you riley i was really
good at math and really bad at money
management and once i realized that
there was a difference between the two
it changed everything so go through
something like financial peace
university maybe now that uh your
arrogance has gone away maybe it'll
stick this time and you'll listen to
grandma and grandpa because they've got
a good head on their shoulders
it's just common sense you're fine man
uh you didn't do anything that most of
us haven't done or wouldn't do the trick
is to um
learn and change because continuing to
do the same thing over and over again
expecting the different a different
result is the definition of insanity
mark is in peoria hi mark welcome to the
ramsey show
thanks for taking a call dave
sure what's up
hey uh i'm 60 my wife's 65.
i uh
five years i'd like to be retired or
semi-retired
i have no pension no 401
no
so-called retirement fund
but i have accumulated and that's my
business uh we've got 32 rental
properties and i'm in the process
of selling them uh a month ago i sold
well one of my last ones i sold i took
that money paid the last three mortgages
off
uh a week ago
uh close on another one
so i've got about 70 000 sitting in the
bank and
um i've always been
confident in the properties that i've
bought and i know the business but
i would like to start buying mutual
funds and i'm out of my comfort zone
and i guess i'm terrified to you know
i've watched uh american greed over the
years and you've always talked about
smart investor pros that you have
but uh that being said um i'm out of my
comfort zone and
um i'm a little skeptical or scared of
starting to put the money in mutual
funds
wow how much these 32 houses so far
would you get you should have more than
700
well no no well i mean
we live i'm in the midwest
midwestern part of the country all right
i tell you what you hang on through this
break we come back we'll talk about it
see what's going on and see if we can
help you with this process
this is the ramsey shack
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're talking with mark in
peoria illinois he just sold 32 rentals
thinking of putting the money into
mutual funds but he knows real estate at
65 years old is comfortable with that
and is scared about mutual funds is that
a fair summary what you told me so far
yes i i haven't sold 32 i have 32. oh i
misunderstood the last few i've sold
been in the 60 to 70 thousand dollar
range okay they're now nice small well
maintained bungalows are ranchers
usually
so why are you making the decision to
get out of the real estate business and
into the mutual fund business
well uh i'm tired of it there's with 32
properties there's a lot of maintenance
i'm a one
one-man show i pretty much do everything
i've had
one person helped me throughout the
years and right now i haven't been able
to
get anybody to help me in the last six
or nine months there's just nobody out
there that will
i can hire
so you've got 32 individual single
family homes
yeah a couple couple
two three you know a couple of duplexes
and three units mixed in there but
majority of them are single family
houses what's the total value of the
whole portfolio
uh which is just about everything uh
including my house that i live in is
about 2.1 million good for you well done
well done well thank you well i'm not
sure that uh if i were in your shoes i
would make the leap to 100 mutual funds
from 100 real estate what i would
consider is some different kinds of real
estate
you're in the highest hassle factor type
of real estate
um and uh if you're if you're gonna i
don't you're talking about selling the
entire portfolio off right
well
i'm thinking three quarters
really slow down i might consider buying
a commercial property that's income
producing whether it be an office
building
or something that has a lot less
maintenance issue and a lot less hassle
with the cl with the uh tenant issue
the number of times i mean i've got i've
got several of both and the number of
times i get a call from a commercial
building versus we get a call i don't
get a call but our our team does our
real estate team does
versus the number of times we get a call
off a single family home is i mean
commercials just about a tenth of the
hassle
and so you could take
you know three-quarters of these you
know 20 of these houses at 25 of these
houses and convert them into a different
kind of real estate if you wanted to
uh if you don't want to it's okay as far
as mutual funds go it's just like real
estate the first time you bought a piece
of real estate you didn't know what you
were doing it was scary
all right the more you did that real
easy the more you did it the more you
became familiar with it the more you
studied it the more you knew the
neighborhoods the more confident you
became
in real estate because of your knowledge
level
and so mutual funds are going to be the
same way click on smart vester at
ramseysolutions.com get with the
smartvestor pro they have the heart of a
teacher that's why we use that
measure
as one of the ways we vet them whether
we will endorse them or not
they have to have the heart of a teacher
because i don't want people putting
money in something they don't understand
because you are always scared then so
you need to begin the process of
learning a whole new type of investing
and
just work on it and just learn
and you can wade in you don't have to go
all in at one time there's nothing
driving this except you're just tired of
fooling with rental property yeah and
hopefully i don't know that his income
if all these rentals are producing that
income but if you get rid of three
quarters of your rentals that might be
three quarters of your income so just be
thinking about that if it's tied up in
mutual funds mutual funds you can pull
the income off yeah i mean you can you
can income it can produce you you put
two million dollars or million dollars
in mutual funds it should produce a
hundred thousand bucks
yeah know you don't have to leave the
growth in there you can pull it off so
he can live off of the income there just
as well but the truth is the real
estate's gonna make more money than
mutual funds but it does have a higher
hassle factor
it has more you know more to do and
you've got to get out of the business of
doing the maintenance yourself that's
just not a good long-term plan that just
steals your joy
it just you know when you start out it's
like kind of cool because i got a hammer
on my belt and all this but yeah real
quick that crap gets old i know how to
do it all but i'm not doing it all all
right let's go to jordan and lee in
albany new york they are debt free leah
hi guys how are you
hey you doing good how much have you
paid off
so we paid off a hundred and five
thousand dollars in about three years
good for you
and your range of income during that
three years
so we started off at forty thousand
dollars and we wound up at a hundred and
seventeen 117 000 at the end good for
you wow what do y'all do for a living
well i'm a dietician
and then i'm a special education teacher
cool well you definitely increased your
income during this time what was the 105
000 worth of debt
so we had a loan uh to lea's parents we
had a loan on a bmw we had leah's
student loans and then we also had my
student loans
whoa
okay and uh making 40 grand
yeah to start with yeah they were
working with one income at the time
yeah and and that beamer is just looking
at you in the driveway
yeah it was nice but it wasn't that nice
yeah really so so what happened 36
months ago that put you guys on this
journey
well we uh we got engaged really is sort
of where that boiled up i had known
about you for years
and
when marriage was on the table you know
it was time to get serious with the
finances
who had the beamer
jordan
who had the most student loans
uh jordan as well also me yep she's very
quickly been paying them off for a while
okay
so uh that see i was still accumulating
when we got married ah okay good very
good how'd you get connected to our plan
well um i had heard about you when i was
in college just listening to christian
radio and uh your show would pop on
every now and then and i found it
fascinating
so i didn't necessarily take all the
principles and apply them but i listened
to the advice and then when time came to
get serious about it i knew where to
turn
wow
way to go you guys
wow so uh what did you do to get out of
debt what do you tell people the secret
to getting out of debt is well the first
thing we paid off our parents debt first
and then we sold the beemer
that'll do it that'll do it
so are the parents are both sets of
parents off in the background just
cheering you on
certainly yeah
yep um we had a little bit of skepticism
but also a little bit of uh cheering on
okay healthy mix that's a good thing
that's good who are your biggest
cheerleaders
so i'd like to give a shout out to my
brother robbie who was definitely a
cheerleader in the process and is going
through the same process himself
all right
yeah and then other than that we we
cheered each other on and we kept each
other honest with it yeah and uh field
it that way well congratulations on your
success we're really proud of you we're
cheering you on for sure
well done how's it feel now that you're
free
it feels good i was expecting almost to
have um
more freedom with money but there's also
goals that we have
now the next baby steps so i don't just
get to spend my money on whatever but
yeah
but cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status of choice right so they
lived it there we go this is real i love
it you guys
well done yeah you'll get whatever car
you want later you drive like no one
else later you can drive like no one
else you
live like no one else later you can live
and give like no one else so you paid a
price to win congratulations will you go
back in debt
no never absolutely not okay had all
this fun you want then
good well way to go you guys we're very
very proud of you got a copy of
the total money makeover for you to give
away and encourage someone to get their
journey started and we've also got a
copy of the legacy journey and uh
that's for you guys because that's the
next chapter in your story to change
your whole lives your family tree you're
in the process of doing that
very well done you'll be baby steps
millionaires before we know it you'll be
calling in to talk about that so
congratulations all right jordan and
leah in albany new york 105 000 paid off
in 36 months making 40 to 117. count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
you gotta love it well done you guys
well done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the new podcast on the ramsey
networks called the fine print
10 episodes of things that you might or
might not know are not a good idea and
george will explain it to you the one
that came out this week is on credit
scores the dirty truth the dirty truth
of the dirty fico score oh filthy dirty
filthy filthy 50 50. all right check it
out guys you won't you'll be amazed it's
a great podcast i have enjoyed it uh on
my walks and runs in the mornings i i
get to listen to a lot of george and he
does a great job all right here we go
lee is in st louis hi lee welcome to the
ramsay show
hey haley hey dave how's it going great
man what's up
hey so my wife and i own a small
catering business we do a lot of big
corporations we go to a place like
walmart and fedex and we've been pretty
successful with it for the past two
years and we're looking to buy some
ground and build a house
and i was just curious on what your take
is on buying ground versus how much to
spend versus building a house
well when the uh when the whole thing is
done
the mortgage that you end up with
does not need to be more than a fourth
of your take-home pay on a 15-year fixed
rate
and okay the ratio of ground to house
can vary
uh and you know if you're if you're
buying a big track of ground obviously
that you're probably gonna have a higher
ratio of land cost versus house than you
would if you bought a simple lot and
built on it a subdivision lot generally
is going to be around 20
of the total price
if you buy you know a standard
subdivision lot if you spend
you know 100 000 bucks on a how on a lot
you're gonna drop about a half million
dollar you're gonna have a half million
dollar project total so about four
hundred thousand on the house that's
about that's a fairly standard ratio but
it's not a rule
and there's nothing wrong with it being
different if you want to buy a big track
of ground and build a small house on it
because you wanted a farm type setting
there's nothing wrong with that at all
that doesn't mean you did something
yeah we're quite a bit ways out of st
louis and uh so we're going to be buying
a three acre track of wood
and then
we working the ground and building our
dream home on there cool
good
yeah so uh we're hoping to get the land
for about 60 000
and then uh build our house on that so i
know yeah the ratio between land and
house
mean it what are you thinking you're
going to spend on the house on the
construction uh
you know we're hoping you know between
you know 400 000 i think
that's what we're going to be
comfortable with after after getting the
land um so that's about that's about a
20 ratio again you're not far off of
that yeah
so um you're a little higher on that but
it's not it's not the other world
everything you're saying is fine i mean
um
in some cases you may be in you're in an
area where the you're far enough out
that the land cost has gone down you're
three acres for 60 grand anywhere in
america that's a pretty good deal
you know and so um where where abouts
outside of st louis are you
effingham illinois
oh yeah absolutely yeah we've got an
affiliate there yeah
very good yeah uh
yeah so we're just looking to buy a
little check to land and start our start
our dream home
absolutely
i don't see anything any reason not to
do it as long as when you're finished
460 000 is
on a mortgage on a 15 year would depend
on how much cash you put into the deal
but your net mortgage
cannot be more than a fourth of your
take-home pay should not be more than a
fourth of your take-home pay
on a 15-year fix because otherwise you
end up house poor
yeah and we experienced that we we did
an episode on the fine print on the
housing gold rush and we talked to
people who got into these houses we've
taken calls where people go dave i'm 50
of my take-home pays going towards this
mortgage and it's crushing me so that's
it really comes down to the ratios and
math on this where you can breathe and
you have margin to attack your other
goals and invest and give and do all
these things to where the house payment
isn't bearing down on you it's a big
deal all right matthew's with us in
little rock arkansas hi matthew how are
you
doing well how are you sir better than i
deserve what's up
oh not a lot i just want to start off by
thanking you and the team for everything
y'all do a few years ago i was able to
make a jump into doing um
my dream business from my day job and i
would have never been in one position to
do that if it weren't for the principals
y'all teach so the value all you all
bring is uh awesome and i'm forever
grateful well thank you sir
yes sir down to my question um my wife
and i have a three-year-old son we are
starting to want to talk about a college
fund getting together we're wondering
about the difference between a 529 plan
and a custodial account
both my wife and i have been
to college however kind of went the
budget route and
if my son ever did want to do anything
outside of college business oriented
like we do i would want him to be able
to convert that and i was just curious
on your thoughts of the 529 versus the
custodial account
well
um
even as mad as we are about the student
loan debt
and some of the ridiculous decisions
people are making in the education world
we're not against education
around here and so um
you know there's no shame in going into
the trades at all
and sometimes you're going you're a
diesel mechanic a welder can make more
uh than somebody with a master's degree
in sociology right now
and so um you know you have to be
careful about your decisions on your
career path and what you spend to become
whatever it is you're going to become
uh and so no there's no shame in any of
that all of those are valid careers uh
you've got to decide that but um
but i will tell you this
spending some money on knowledge
is going to be a good thing for this kid
whether you whether it's a classic
higher education four-year degree or
whether it's a community college or
whether it's an associate's degree or
whether it's a trade school of some kind
that they're plugging into so all of
that can be used for the 529 the 529
gross tax-free the custodial does not
that's it
that's the big difference
uh the custodial does have an
interesting feature in that you control
the money until they're 21 you do not in
a 529.
interesting okay you control it only
until they're 18 in the 529 and so if
during that three year period of time
they continue to have no brains
um then you can have more say in it if
they have if it's a custodial account uh
when our kids were growing up the 529s
and esa's were not there so we did
custodial accounts
okay and um so i'm not afraid of them
and and since it is basically the mutual
fund people don't know what that means
anytime you open up a a bank account in
a kid's name of any kind mutual fund or
otherwise it's a custodial account
because you cannot do contracts until
you're 18 so you cannot open an account
so basically you're opening an account
in their name but you are the custodian
you're the one doing the transaction and
so if you open a savings account at the
bank if your 16 year old has a checking
account at the bank it has you on it as
a custodian because they cannot legally
do that in any state
you cannot do contracts in the state so
and when you open an account you're
entering into a contract so these are
all custodial accounts but when you open
a custodial account with a mutual fund
company
you the the money is in the kid's name
technically from a tax standpoint and so
until it makes enough money to
go past their standard deduction
there's no taxes on the account so the
account can grow to pretty good size
because it's not going to make enough
return to even be taxable so it's going
to grow tax-free
for the first
big chunk of time the custodial account
will but the 529 um i like the fact that
it points them towards knowledge and
points them towards education because
even as mad as we are about student
loans and the stupidity in the higher
education world we still want to point
people towards
education higher education trade school
education education of some kind no
education is not the answer to the
student loan problem yeah and with the
the esa or the 529 i love that tax-free
growth and you can pass it on it can go
to a different family member there's a
lot of things you can do with that even
if they don't go the traditional route
but that growing from three years old to
18 that's a massive growth even if
you're putting in a little chunk of
change every year a thousand dollars 2
000
15 years so if you're watching this kid
and as he ages uh he's less and less
likely to be higher ed
more more likely to be starting a
business or something else um you know
you may want to divert and put less into
the 529 and open a custodial as its twin
sister to run with it
that would be fine
to have some money in each
uh but i i
there's something positive about going
this is your college fund that's your
college fund you're brainwashing them
the whole time they're going to college
uh this is your college fund that's your
college fund that's your college fund
mine looked at their college fund and
helped me calculate the mutual funds
when they were 12 and 10 and so it kind
of there's kind of this assumption that
well there must we must be going to
college and so it's a good thing and i'm
glad i'm glad that my three kids and i
and my wife all have four-year degrees i
think that's a positive thing you just
want to do education in a smart way
where we've
somewhat lost our minds in this country
there was a lot in that side and i
you'll find out why when borrowed future
launches tomorrow as a feature
full-length film yeah there's
documentary coming out check it out on
apple tv google play google play and um
amazon prime amazon prime thank you very
much george and borrowed future.com you
can rent it there as well this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your
[Music]
story live from the headquarters of
ramsey solutions broadcasting from the
dollar car rental studios it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host thank you for joining us america we
are so glad you are here open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five george campbell joins
me as my co-host today he is ramsey
personality and host of many of our
podcasts on the ramsey network including
the new one the fine print which is uh
extremely popular be sure you check it
out a new episode dropped this week
on uh the credit score debacle it's a
big one
it's a big one
yeah anytime you can do something where
everyone in america thinks they're
measuring their money by your score
you've done a big job
it's impressive it is impressive i mean
when you were growing up that that was
not a thing
people weren't measuring their lives
against a number yep and now they are
d is with us dee is in kansas city hi
dee how you doing
hey dave i'm doing great thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
well um it's a little overwhelming um
today i just got a check that um we
inherited um just right under two
million dollars how much and
two million
two million dollars
wow
who who left you this
well my mom and dad but my my dad worked
really really hard and
lived very conservatively and um you
would have never known it growing up
wow
wow
way very long ago really what did that
how long ago did he pass
um
he passed
about a little over a year then my mom
just passed um
just not much very long ago oh wow wow
right together how long were they
married yeah
oh goodness 60 plus years oh my goodness
well i'm sorry for your loss that leaves
a big hole in your life
yeah but yeah it's just a lot to take in
and we just want to be wise um
it's just a lot all at once
you get all um of financial people that
try to tell you do this do that and we
just my head spinning to be honest
um we've worked hard my husband and i um
hey my husband's retired and he's 62 and
i'm 57 and i work part-time what is your
net worth before you got this check
um we
have about let's see
1.4 million okay so you were already
millionaires
yeah but um this just kind of all just
happened my husband retired and i mean
we just been working towards this day
let me tell you how you got 1.4 million
slow and steady
yes sir and you did it without all of
these financial sharks that are swimming
around you in circles right now like a
jimmy buffett song
yeah
okay yeah we just plugged it on you know
how you get rid of those sharks you
shoot at them with a gun
and they swim off
i'm i'm being metaphorical okay i'm not
saying don't really shoot somebody okay
you you're in kansas it could happen but
um yeah no the uh uh
run them off unless they're your
financial person that you're already
we're dealing with run them off
okay gotcha yeah they're they're there
for the wrong reasons at the wrong time
they have violated their their lack of
class disqualifies them goodbye
all right all right now then so rule
number one
slow down
okay
going fast is bad
going slow is good
a lot of peace in that in there
yeah your dad moved slowly
your dad moved slow
you got to 1.4 slow
and the way you're going to properly
handle 2 million extra
is slow
calm down there's no rush
there's no one in a hurry a tornado is
not coming you're fine
okay number two
don't put money in anything
you don't understand
it's your job
to understand it but guess what you were
already a millionaire so you already
understand how to manage wealth you were
already managing wealth
but maybe you need to bone up on it just
a little bit maybe you need to polish up
on your skills a little
nothing wrong with that okay with the
extra weight of this extra
responsibility
so rule one slow down
two don't put money in anything you
don't understand
three do not work with anyone in any
field anywhere in the financial world at
all for that matter anyone anywhere
probably but certainly in the financial
field unless they have the heart of a
teacher
okay and the sharks that are circling
right now don't have the heart of a
teacher get rid of them
all right 85 percent of the people in
the insurance business in the investment
business in the real estate business in
the estate planning business are sales
people 15 of them are teachers
you're looking for one of the 15 percent
and i made that number up by the way but
i'm pretty close
all right so you have the heart of a
teacher
as your advisor
they are not telling you what to do
and you're expected to do it blindly
because you're going to understand it
before you do it and you're going to
slow down
can you handle one more rule
i sure can
ask yourself
before you do the investment before you
make the move
is this honoring to my father's memory
okay
and the reason i'm having you do that is
your dad was a hero
i want you managing money like he did
and if you think he's in heaven smiling
because you're smart then that's
probably because you're smart
and if you're if you invest in something
you go my dad is up there shaking his
head going uh uh uh uh uh that one's
stupid
and then you know you're doing the wrong
thing right
that's correct yeah
because your dad was unassuming and
steady and wise
consequently
proverbs says a godly man leaves an
inheritance to his children's children
that's your dad
okay
if you do those four things kiddo you're
going to be just fine george what do you
want to add one no i just want you guys
to start dreaming about what this does
for you because what it does it gives
you freedom and it gives you options and
so start dreaming about what you want to
do to make this a blessing i don't want
it to give you anxiety i want it to to
give you that feeling of what could we
do with this money do we want to uh you
know there's three things you can do
give save spend where do we want to give
a portion of this how do we want to
spend some of this and enjoy it and how
do we want to save this or put it
towards other goals maybe you want to
buy investment property or do something
absolutely wild you have the freedom to
do that now
hey dee
you're more able to handle this than you
think you are
you already had 1.4 million
you're not dumb
you know more than half the people that
are purporting to give you advice
trust your instincts you have good
instincts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show if
you've ever wondered if an online will
is right for you
if you need a trust do you need a mirror
image will what kind of powers of
attorney do you need well you hear me
say everyone needs a will but i get a
lot of questions asking if a simple
online will is right for someone's
specific situation
with those questions in mind our team
built a quiz
to help you find the right option for
you the quiz gives you custom results
based on the basic info like if you're
married or single where you live even if
you even the size of your estate it
helps you understand exactly what you
need for your specific situation and
everyone needs a will
take the quiz to figure out what kind of
will you need to protect your family and
your wishes text the word quiz
to 33 789 it's free
check it out for yourself if an online
solution works for your situation we'll
send you a promo code for 20 off your
will with our ramsey trusted provider
text quiz
to 33
789 quiz to 33789
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from chris in tennessee with covid cases
ramping up again i'm wondering how to
prepare in case we have lockdowns again
my profession isn't one where i can work
from home what steps can i take now to
protect my family in case i'm not able
to work for several weeks
interesting
well uh i don't like people going into
paranoia uh about what could and and
what ifs but several weeks sounds like
something that could be easily covered
with an emergency fund
where if you for some reason got laid
off fired you'd be taken care of for
three to six months yeah but it sounds
like there's more behind this question
than just a financial question
yeah there's
he's afraid
um
and rightly so um because we've all had
our
uh world uh turned upside down and
shaking like a freaking snow globe
so um
you know we don't know what's gonna
happen next and it's not even the
disease you worry about all the time
it's whether the government loses its
mind or not um and
well that's not even in question anymore
but the um
uh it's just a matter on from state to
state locality to locality how much crap
you're gonna get so he's in tennessee so
he's safer than most yeah he's probably
very safe in that regards um
huh
the thing about the stuff we teach
george
while we get criticized for it to be um
overly simplified or one-size-fits-all
or primitive or not for people with
money it's only for broke people or
whatever we get all these you know these
critics on this stuff and
um
the reason they're wrong
is not because
we're smarter or something like that the
things we teach are common sense
biblically based
financial principles
and the interesting thing about these
principles is they work during
times of crisis
and they work during times of prosperity
they're the only set of principles that
work during both times
and so if you're out of debt
principle number one
you have money in savings for an
emergency principle number two
you're living on a plan principle number
three
you are not self-centered so that you're
generous principle number four you're
surrounding yourself with like-minded
people principle number five
uh you're diversified
spread your portions to seven years to
eight for you do not know when disaster
may come upon the land
ecla ecclesiastes says in the bible
diversification is a biblical concept
it's also a financial concept
but you know
you know we're going to
live on less than we make we're not in
debt we're not co-signing debt debt's
off the table we're investing wisely
what you are then is you have gone the
slower route and you have built the
brick house like the third pig
and so my answer to chris is be the
third pig
you remember the three little pigs right
the first two little pigs got their
house blown down by the big bad wolf
called pandemic and then he came over to
the other little pig who had a lot of
money in the bank and no debt and they
blew any huffing puff then he went to
somebody else's house
and um they said no bacon here buddy
and so uh you know that that's the story
we all remember it right
so be the third pig we're gonna need to
print up t-shirts be the third pig right
and so if you're the third pig
you are prospering during
wonderful times and you're prospering
during the pandemic
and
it has a tendency when you're not broke
to help you avoid paranoia
because this one sounds a little bit
paranoid yeah and i think a lot of this
is fear and we dealt with this you know
during the pandemic we realized we were
in a position to go we need to help
people not just with money but with fear
and what was what was the antidote you
found to fear in the last 18 months we
were quoting dr john deloney the whole
time facts are your friends when you're
in the middle of a crisis
facts are your friends not feelings so
we need to go to reality here and so
you know the truth is chris if you're in
tennessee if you get out of your house
and walk around
you're not going to see a society that
is shut down by covid
uh even though there was a slight spike
in cases which now are back down but um
you're not going to see
facts before your eyes that match your
words on this paper
the facts are your friends feelings are
not your friends and worry is a feeling
paranoia is a feeling
concern
over observable
craziness and stupidity
is a fact
and that's okay to be that i'm that
i don't know what's gonna happen next
you know who knows what their people are
going to do and i truly am more
concerned
about an out-of-control government than
i am the disease
both are scary uh
one of them though is not um
well anyway it's just yeah so you just
if you'll get out of your house and walk
around sir
and get out in the sunshine and exercise
you need some vitamin d
and um walk around see human beings
interacting that are not freaked out
they're not scared they're they're i
think you're going to have a different
conclusion
into your situation
but
to answer your question about worrying
be the third pig
because these principles work in good
times and they work in bad times
george i remember um
2008
when the
housing
bubble burst when the hedge funds had
securitized
subprime mortgages and stupidity had run
amok
and wall street brought the american
real estate market to its knees with it
the stock market stock market dropped in
half
bush is transitioning into obama
neither one of them could find their
butt with both hands at the time
and um it was a disaster
i mean it was scary
and i i remember distinctly i was on fox
news
i was in new york and i finished
cavuto's show kavuto and i've been
friends for years and cavuto is very
very smart
neil's a very bright man
we've known each other 20 years probably
and we're between breaks and
the octaves in his voice had changed he
was scared
because we're watching that red ticker
tape go across the dadgum thing you know
six feet tall across the side of the new
york building and the stock market's
going down gold prices are going up all
these volatility signs are not good
and he said you think we're going to be
okay and i said i know we're going to be
okay
and i went and sat down there's a
steakhouse right across the street from
there and sharon and i left the fox
green room went across sat down ordered
a steak and i'm looking at that dadgum
ticker tape and suddenly that chill went
down my spine
and i thought i wonder if we're gonna be
okay
and sharon and i were talking about it
that night at dinner and we said why are
we not scared
because everybody else at that point was
in freak out mode i mean we had
congressmen that were like crying on the
television because they couldn't get the
stimulus package passed you remember the
stimulus package you know that kind of
crap they were going crazy
and it was just like this panic
literally their voice octaves were
changing and i said why are we not
freaked out she said
it could be our faith and i said well
sometimes christians get afraid what's i
mean you're not christian i mean you
don't get afraid
and she said well could be we've got
several million dollars in the bank of
no doubt oh well that could be that that
might have something to do with it
be the third pig chris
be the third pig
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
george camel ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage
joy is with us from san diego california
hi joy how are you i'm doing good how
are you welcome to tennessee so good to
have you how much debt have you paid off
about a hundred and six thousand dollars
how long did that take about 45 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time about 59 to 85. good
for you what do you do for a living
by day i am a
buyer i work in supply chain
and i do a lot of other things on the
side okay whatever it takes huh good for
you well done what what kind of debt was
the 106 000 that you eliminated i had
student loans there was a car some
school loans from family members
i had a nine dollar library fine that i
didn't know about and a handful of
credit cards i can't believe you had a
nine dollar
library fine
that's just straight to the top of the
desk i thought you know i thought and i
thought joy was gonna be one of the good
ones and then i found out she had a nine
dollars was it one book can you tell us
that was it worth it
it was one book and it was four years
old and they never even told me i had a
fine oh there you go see that's how they
do you oh we're at the library they're
that way joy good for you that's amazing
well done you've been at this a while
almost four years you've been hustling
and grinding to get through this
congratulations
that is quite and sticking with anything
that long's a great task but you've been
at it so what started this ramsay
journey of you getting out of debt
so i was already wanting to get out of
debt because i i'm an ordained pastor
and i can't do that job as my full-time
job with a 900 student loan payment oh
there's that there's that and so i
i was working a plan and it was not
working my plan was no good and
i started following somebody's budget
workbook and i decided to do it on my
blog because nobody knew
like people knew i had student loans but
nobody including me knew how bad it was
and so i did the first page of the
workbook and it was to total up all your
assets and all your debts and i wrote a
blog post about it
and a friend of mine saw the post
and sent me the link to her debt free
screen
and said this might be motivating for
you if you listen to this podcast and so
i listened and
my first debt free screen that i heard i
was
sold and a few weeks later that other
workbook kind of went out the window
and
everything the credit cards are gone and
everything's gone from there yeah wow
good for you
good for you
wow that's fun
i love a good friend that says this
might be encouraging to you that's
different than yeah listen to this
you're stupid i got i got both kinds of
friends but this might be encouraging to
you that's nice yeah that's really nice
well done
very well done so joy tell me this what
was the what were the sacrifices that
you made you said you were doing a lot
of stuff on the side to bring in some
extra income what were the sacrifices
that caused you to pay off six figures
in under four years well i worked a lot
of saturdays doing websites and ebay and
not going
hiking and not doing things with family
and friends i did some things did some
free things but i said no to a lot of
things in that process
a lot of
really interesting dinners
[Laughter]
very creative
what was the worst interesting dinner i
don't know that any of them were like
bad but people would give me food people
were really supportive and would give me
food and so i'd have to go find how many
lentil recipes do you know
wow oh that's wonderful they would just
donate you food yes oh when we were
getting out of debt we were broke sharon
would make tuna fish sandwiches and i
would put them in the refrigerator at
the office and by the time i got them
out of the refrigerator at lunch they'd
be soggy
when i smell tuna fish this day
it makes my net worth go down
i it's it's broke people food for me you
know and you get a smell off of
something that's broke people food that
you equate with this time you'll never
be able to eat it again it runs it it
just ruins it so it's not it's not diet
food it's broke people food so it's just
like oh man that's cool that's fun good
for you what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is you did an
incredible job by the way so i have
three one is the budget but really
actually looking at the budget like week
to week because
my tendency would be to have a budget
and then
do my spending and then come back to the
end of the month and go what happened
like it didn't follow it right and so or
you get sloppy you lose you didn't you
forgot you spent money there yeah and so
for me like
i have to try to touch it every week and
look at it make sure my receipts are
entered and
keep track of things week to week
because if i don't touch it i get sloppy
perfect
the second one is that sharing takes
away the shame i heard somebody say that
once that's good but if i hadn't shared
on a blog post four years ago
like i wouldn't be here
because i wouldn't even know
yeah right but then there's this whole
other piece of it's not something that i
have to be afraid about somebody finding
out that i've got this mountain of debt
because everybody knows i'm destroying
this mountain of debt
i am a girl who pays off debt and so um
i am joy who pays off debt it's like you
know you kind of pop the balloon and
then there's no longer something for
somebody to find out that's like this
bad thing it's just
it has no power over you anymore yeah um
and and the third one is you really have
to cut up the credit cards i
paid off all my credit cards in 2012
and then i paid off all my credit cards
in 2018. see what happened here
i see a friend yeah so i know a lot of
people who tell me they want to do the
points thing or whatever and they are
adults and they can make their own
decisions but for me
that was i was not going to do that a
third time no it was done there's a
youtube video with evidence they're all
gone i had to put an end to that yeah
yeah that's good that that's very smart
it's very wise there's something that
happens
when you burn the ships yep you can't go
back cortez right and so yeah it changes
the whole uh
changes the whole thing and you go okay
i'm really going to do this i'm going to
have to live on a budget because i don't
have a plastic crutch anymore right and
i'm going to have to i'm going to have
to have my emergency fund because i
don't have a plastic crutch anymore
and um it forces you
to to finish up and get rid of any ish
that you were doing it's no ramsay-ish
you're going to you're going to be pure
down the line and that that when you do
all that you're exactly right that's
that's when you see the results
do i trust god or do i trust a credit
card to get me out of an emergency
who is your provider
who's your provider master
card who named that anyway
yeah or god there you go that's very
good powerful powerful well done joy
good job who were your biggest
cheerleaders sounds like you had a bunch
of them i had a bunch of them now there
were some people that thought i was
insane when they saw the video of me
cutting up my credit cards yeah that's
good that was that was nuts but broke
people are making fun of your financial
plan you are right on track
but my my family has been amazing i'm
part of a writers group the acfw in
orange county
and
two churches that i've been part of
during this season coast city church in
oceanside and citywide mosaic in
temecula yeah and these people
cheered me on and wouldn't let me pay
for food and gave me hand-me-down
clothes and gave me massive amounts of
things to sell on ebay like i didn't go
and buy things to sell in my ebay store
people just kept giving me it just kept
coming when i was done i had to clear it
all out of my house because there was
still so much stuff yeah so mosaic erwin
mcmanus uh no it's citywide mosaic and
temecula okay so it's different than
mcmanus yes okay all right because he's
got his called mosaic there too all
right cool very cool good for you
well done well done well done well done
man she's impressive very i don't think
there's any stopping joy no she's going
to cut up anything that comes her way
[Laughter]
that'll work well i mean once you set
your face towards something
and um you know there's something about
the power of confession
uh it takes away
you know
nothing has secrets have power over you
but when you when there aren't secrets
there's no power and so you know i've
often said uh you know once i went broke
i got over worrying about what you
people think and so
my failures are my biggest part of my
brand yeah so i just kind of relish in
them because it's kind of who we are
i've got a phd in the umb and if you
don't like that shut up you're wrong so
all right joy way to go 106 000 paid off
45 months make it 59 to 85. we got a
copy of the legacy journey total money
makeover for you count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three
two
one i'm dead free
this is how it's done
45
months coming to that moment
that is true joy yeah literally and
figuratively
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day philippians 1
27 whatever happens conduct yourselves
in a manner worthy of the gospel of
christ
then whether i come and see you or only
hear about you in my absence i will know
that you stand firm
in the one spirit
striving together
as one
for the faith for the faith of the
gospel
babe ruth said never let the fear of
striking out keep you from playing the
game
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
hayden is with us in oklahoma city hi
hayden welcome to the ramsey show thank
you how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
so i'm 25 my wife and i just got done
paying off some student loans great
don't quite have our emergency fund set
up yeah you know where it should be yet
uh but you know i'm a planner so we're
sitting talking with um you know the
companies we work for and then some
financial advisors in the area about
setting up a 401k and ira and stuff so
my company so the question i have in my
company only matches up to half a
percent so i'm wondering how much i then
you know take out for
that side and how much i go to the
my financial advisor uh with a just
regular irv
so if in the baby steps you said you
almost have that emergency fund ready to
go once you're at baby step four then
we're gonna put 15 and you're wondering
how do i do that in what order uh
because of this half percent match and
we like match the best so match is gonna
beat pretty much everything out there
because it's free money we're gonna
follow that up by going to that roth ira
that you mentioned and you can max that
out uh followed by going back to the
401k and you said you and your wife are
looking into what options she has uh and
it won't make a difference as far as 15
is gonna be across your household income
and so as long as you're you're doing
that total across it uh i don't know if
does she have a match as well
yeah she does and hers is um it's like
up to three percent and then after three
percent it um
every other percent and then it maxes
out five okay so you want to do all
matches
first
so let me let me back up you kind of
have to back into this
what george said is exactly right match
beats roth
beats traditional
so that's your order of attack is
matched to roth for traditional and roth
can be roth 401k or roth ira either one
okay but a roth without a match does not
keep up with a traditional with a match
or a roth with a match either one so
match is best now so just take your
whole household income times 0.15 that's
the number we're trying to get to
okay then you do your half percent match
and that gives you a number what's the
number as compared to you deduct that
from the 15 percent
that not the percentage points but you
say that let's just use a round number
let's say you made a hundred thousand
dollars so your number is fifteen
thousand dollars you're trying to get to
if you're half a percent is uh
two is a thousand dollars now we got
still gotta do 14 000. if her 3 and then
every other 1 adds up to when we by the
time we do all that to get all that
match that adds up to out of your pocket
another 4 000 well now we're down to 10
000
okay out of that 15. and so you start
spending off of your 15 000 or your 15
number
uh first by match
then by roth and then by traditional
george is exactly right that's exactly
how you approach this and that's going
to get you there but
sometimes people it's a little bit
confusing because it's like what it's a
percentage of her
income on hers and half percent of your
income on yours
and you're trying to how's that equate
to the 15 percent well you can't mix it
up because you got percentage of two
different numbers so uh you just go with
an actual hard actual dollar amount the
nominal figure the real number
and then use that number to chunk out of
until you get all the way down to zero
yeah and it works the same way if he
goes i'm going to do 15 out of my income
she does 15 out of hers that simplifies
it numbers wise and gets you to the same
place
yeah
uh but we might not do that
because she might have a better match
and we might end up doing a bunch of it
over on her side yeah so you use the
whole household number
because if you if you split it up and
you do 15 of her income and she runs
down through that same formula
match versus roth versus traditional
uh you might miss out on he might have a
better match or she might have better if
there's a big match exactly if one or
the other has a match the other one
doesn't you want to be sure you're
chunking out the whole thing look at it
holistically
uh vishwas is with us in uh cincinnati
hi vis welsh how are you
hi miss dave this is a great honor to
speak to you thank you so much for
taking the call sure what's up
uh i'm a legal immigrant from india i
make about uh 53 to 50k a year uh i have
eight thousand dollars in debt that is
seven thousand dollars in credit card
and a thousand dollars remaining in my
personal loan that i took couple of
years ago um
i
it's due to my visa restrictions it's a
single household income i'm the only
person out to work right now i i
listened to your shows and i was trying
to try and see if there's any
possibility i could take up some
additional work and kind of reduce my
debt i have already scrapped off all my
credit cards i've just kept one just in
case i needed because we might i did not
have much of an emergency cash i have
like close to 500 600
i just just to be on a safer side any
expenses
it's a two-part question
would you have any suggestions unless
otherwise i take a different job uh or
go back to my country i don't see any
other ways i could tackle my
expenses to become debt snowball and
reduce the debt you have any suggestions
for that
and the main reason is that i'm also
planning for a house because my family
got bigger
i have thirty five thousand dollars at
my home country which i could probably
get it over here for my down payment but
even even though i'm going to be staying
here for only for two years because of
these restrictions i'm not sure if it's
an economically viable option to
purchase off the house
and because my family is getting bigger
what's the probability of your visa
renewal it's a work visa i assume
yes sir it is so i would say it's
probably close to 50 percent uh
because it's it's a different extension
then it might be a different scenario so
it's close to 50 percentage
and you would have to at least go back
to india for a period of time right
that's right uh what i see like my wife
and me we just became new parents so
the
mental mindset is that if we head out of
this country it would be for good and i
don't she does not want to even come
back here
okay so she's indian as well
yes yes okay all right cool
all right no i would not buy a house
okay it sounds like you're leaving and
not gonna come back
okay
in two years there's not enough time to
turn a house and make a profit on it uh
yes i would pull some of your money from
your home country just pay off your debt
be debt-free
okay okay and then let's go ahead and
pile up cash for your future in india
and follow your baby steps in india at
that point uh because that's where you
know basically you got a two-year
stopover here is what you're telling me
and a 50 chance of renewal
um
and if that does not if that renewal
does not occur if it does occur how long
is it extended for
so that's the catchy part if it does
occur uh it would be
extension of every three years so then
it would be another three years after
that
what is the pathway to citizenship look
like
oh that's a very long processor it's
like this process i'm talking about is a
green card so i'm applying for the green
card and it's due it's a work visa
related green card the backlog for
indian citizens is close to 10 to 12
years easily so uh i would still be able
to extend every three years and stay in
this country but uh the green card i
would get only after like probably 20 32
or 30 35 something like that wow
okay
i i don't i don't have much knowledge of
that world uh uh just enough to ask a
semi-intelligent question was all so uh
that's that's shocking to me i'm sorry
wow
um well here's the thing you still work
the financial principles they work uh
the only thing is you're probably going
to step back from
buying a house in this case it's not
going to make sense yeah you said based
on your income you feel like you
couldn't pay this off and i just want to
challenge you and tell you that you can
and people make a lot less and pay off a
lot more so you absolutely can do this
and you've got the money sitting over
there in india so if you can use that to
at least pay off this debt and create an
emergency fund of three to six months
that's going to put you in a really good
spot as you at least finish out this
visa yeah wow hey thank you for the call
sir it's honored to talk with you george
campbell ramsey personality my co-host
today good show george thank you always
a good time nice job james and kelly in
the booth as always i am dave ramsey
your host this is common sense for your
dollars and since we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you